let's start today with Vladimir Putin
and Russia we know that Russian
casualties are mounting we know that
Russia is being drastically affected by
sanctions even if they are undertaking a
public relations campaign to try to make
the case that they're fine and
everything's fine and the latest in this
uh
seemingly interminable Fiasco is Putin
and Russia claiming that the United
States is actually behind an alleged
Ukrainian drone attack which I guess
damaged a flagpole and did nothing else
whereas intelligence analysts are saying
it is far more likely that this is a
Russian false flag than it is something
with American involvement particularly
because it failed so badly if indeed the
goal was to hurt somebody and it's just
blatantly pathetic in terms of the video
that has been released so let's go
through this in pieces NBC news report
Russia claims the U.S is behind the
alleged Ukrainian drone attack on the
Kremlin both Kiev and Washington
strongly denied involvement
in what Moscow said without citing
evidence was an attempt to assassinate
President Vladimir Putin Russia claimed
Thursday the U.S was behind the alleged
drone attack on the Kremlin and said it
was a Ukrainian attempt to kill Putin
this accusation was made without citing
any evidence a less than 24 hours after
Moscow said that it foiled an overnight
drone strike on a building that is the
heart of the country's government and
Putin's residence Kremlin spokesman
Dmitry peskov quite a node of
disinformation claimed Thursday that
Washington Mastermind masterminded the
incident the U.S swiftly rejected the
accusation saying it had nothing to do
with it as did Ukraine now there is
another very interesting piece a CNBC uh
Slash NBC report analysts say Russia
quote likely staged Kremlin drone attack
it blamed on Ukraine and the West
speculation is mounting that Russia
staged the Drone attack on the Kremlin
that it blamed on Ukraine with political
analysts saying there are a number of
reasons why the alleged strike which
Russia called a planned terrorist attack
just doesn't add up Russia accused
Ukraine of attempting to attack the
Kremlin saying the government and Kiev
tried to strike at the heart of Russia's
government
Russian President Putin wasn't injured
in what it characterized as an
assassination attempt in fact Putin had
not been in the Kremlin at the time of
the alleged incident but provided no
evidence Ukraine carried it out Ukraine
denied involvement Russia has often been
accused of plotting false flag attacks
that it can blame on Ukraine and used to
justify or escalate its own military
aggression against the country as the
war drags on into its 15 months so what
do we actually know I mean we know that
there was something on video that looks
like a drone
um it appears as though it hit a
flagpole
Moscow claims it was Ukraine trying to
kill Putin masterminded by the United
States there's no evidence of that
Ukraine denies it the U.S denies it
analysts say it was likely staged now
let's believe it for a second and what I
mean by that is let's believe for a
second that this really was an attempt
by Ukraine masterminded by the United
States to kill Putin couple different
things one we have to believe that an
attack masterminded by the United States
and carried out by Ukraine hit a
flagpole okay not the most uh uh
predictable outcome that we would
imagine
and or secondly
we have to believe that Russia is
admitting that their air defense system
is so poor that enemy drones now just
fly over the Capitol and hit a flagpole
at the Kremlin both of these scenarios
certainly taken together
aren't super easy to believe
and what we do know is that there's a
very long history with Vladimir Putin of
false flag type events of this kind used
to justify whatever and you can go all
the way back to Putin's Ascension to
power with examples of that probably a
topic for another day what we know is
that Russia continues to have huge
losses
Russia believed this would be super easy
when it started last year 15 months ago
and it's probably not easy to keep the
Russian public patriotic and happy as
family members and friends and loved
ones Etc are being killed as a result of
what was supposed to be a very easy
takeover of Ukraine so from a PR
perspective it would be extraordinarily
useful to be able to credibly claim that
the Ukraine with a masterminded by the
United States Ukraine carried out such
an attacker attempted attack and the key
line in all of this is that Russia says
it will respond
what does a response mean what will that
response look like well we don't know
yet but that often is the name of the
game uh create a pretext a surface of
pretext to then justify further
escalations and maybe have a PR impact
to get more people on the side of this
completely hair brained incursion by
Putin and Ukraine when you ask me how
will it end I still have absolutely no
idea
but it's looking like it's going to be
relatively ugly
plastic it's everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year here's something super
simple you can do to reduce plastic and
help the planet a little bit our sponsor
hold on bags is the company making
plastic free trash bags and zip seal
kitchen bags they're just as strong and
high quality as the plastic bags you're
used to hold on bags are 100 percent
plant-based and home compostable meaning
they break down in just weeks not
decades their zip seal kitchen bags come
in sandwich or gallon size to fit all of
your needs whether it's carrots or
crayons at home I put all of my food
waste in a hold on trash bag throw it in
the compost pile and when I throw a hold
on trash bag in my dumpster I love
knowing it's not filling our landfills
and oceans with plastic single use
Plastics harm the planet at every Stage
production disposal decomposition join
the growing movement away from
single-use plastic these products are
really great it's so easy to make the
switch go to hold on bags.com
Pacman and you'll get 20 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below